tutti ragazzi permesso video sono fatti
j
ed oggi siamo trovati su snai per che
poi si pronunciasse leader per una volta
che volevo fare lingue quindi su iphone
ho fatto una cache e come al solito si
corre l'ultima volta che l'ho provato a
fare un record in stachezza del gioco
sono quasi riuscito però sono arrivato
all'ottavo posto che poi allora voi non
sapete perché non l'ho mai spiegato ma
in questo gioco ragazzi ci sono 600
persone c'è scritto la ok ci sono più o
meno 600 un po meno quando io gioco sta
roba arrivare tra i primi 10 significa
che sei davanti quasi a 600 persone
quindi è tanto quindi ragazzi io devo
assolutamente riuscire ad arrivare
davanti a sti deficienti perché non è
possibile che non arrivi prima allora io
sono forte e si prova
[ __ ] non hai mai il nome faringei che
non funzionava usiamo tipo preso mattino
tipo questo funziona in questo modo e
questo malgrado lo sento questo muore
questo crea ed paolo vi al culo cosa ho
fatto rega cosa non è che quest'anno
incula e lo sapevo taccini sua madre
oggi kat all'inizio e per l'amor di dio
fame una roba seria calmo ragazzi
abbiamo trovato la nostra prossima
vittima che era quel deficiente che mi
ha ucciso prima che vi prendono la
rivincita tutta la vita
eccolo qui lo stravedere o ragazzi
indiscutibilmente il mio la mia tattica
quella di passare vicino ai giganti
funziona comunque sono 255 sì ma stai
calma sabrina come vede il preservativo
the city è pronto per l'ultimo ti
ammazzo devi crepare è ora che tenta di
inglobare lista [ __ ]
ma che voglio sono tremila ragazzi la
madonna 5.000 ragazzi 5000 e tantissimo
allora piano l'ultima volta era arivata
tipo a 10 il doppio che era che è
veramente assurdo sono un preservativo
viola
parti
sardi no eh ma l'avete fottuti tutti
siete dei ladri di merda tutti dovete
crepare male mi ha sentito la gamma
ascoltato è crepato male dai anche su
gigante dai come può essere così grosso
non essere tra i primi questo qui no
vabbè 3 lo giuro che ho provato a
sterzare ma nostra vita niente inutile
madonna come rock we are al culetto ce
l'ho fatta ragazzi ce lo fanno non ci
sono automobili qualcuno mi tenta di
prendere i punti quindi li sterzo in
faccia tipo noi invece no è morto un
altro è molti tutti qua
ecco è questo che intendevo ragazzi con
sterzo in faccia e mappe dovete farvi i
cazzi vostri
quanti sono morti i 16 9 morti tutti
ragazzi morti tutti qua 3000 punti 4
mila e va beh ragazzi che è un'orgia di
punti con madonna madonna 6000 7000
ragazzi 7.200 pian piano ci storia
arrivando quando non troppo lento ma
lega abbia un piano sto per entra in
classifica seguono i primi diciotto
deficiente ma armato non ci credo
deficiente brutto orgoglio ne yo morti
tutti morti tutti morti tutti morti più
calmi
cosa succede no o e molto noi è morto
lui non sono sul linguaggio non limonato
ragazzi morto siamo a latina testata ma
per una volta nella vita e non si spiega
come mai ho vinto io mai non lo so mai
spiegato tra non è perché in genere sono
io quello che ci creava su ste cose
vabbè caravan tosto lungo anno con un
solo io mi chiamo per morire come un
pirla stava andando incontro ad un altro
che non ero io
regali non riesco a capire chi sono io
chi sono
[Musica]
quanti punti 10 11mila
oddio solo sesto solo sesto in
classifica c'è un preservativo sesta in
classifica
vai ragazzo allora posso anche vincere
aspettando che crepino gli altri sempre
che è dio
oddio nome da gli rompe i [ __ ] non
mi devi rompere i [ __ ] no no no no
no no no no che cosa aperto questa sia
eletto mi sono pagati in malissimo
13.000 dai odio questo lo ingloba che
invece non mi sa che si è spinto oltre
ho vissuto in mano orribile saper
succede una cosa orribile dai ragazzi
fate morì qualcuno ve prego so è quasi
arrivato primo vi prego cioè no perché
dovete rompermi cazzo perché se tutti
qua no beh oddio oddio l'ansia
oddio morti tutti i porti tutti morti
tutti morti tutti no devi morire anche
tu e germano perché fatto con la
bandiera da tedeschi a lo chiamo germano
vailati di crepati al mare è un killer
giorno ha niente da fare è morto germano
quanto mi dispiace brutti stronzi
ok no oddio croizon salva ragazzi io
vedo la mia vita scorrermi davanti agli
occhi quando passa qualcuno noi ci siamo
lì monatti poi siamo andati ognuno per
la sua strada c'è così nelle relazioni
di oggi afifi ci siamo limonate prove di
te crepa che sono non vinco io tv ci ho
provato
fini ma guarda che deficente stone a
nome della era un per cazzo ma non ho
che questo ci sta o madonna dai lea t
dal fatto che sono nono sono nono sono
di nuovo in classifica da ieri ora di
morali come la madonna 13 mila sono
sesto punti quanti punti quanti punti a
quando ci sono tipo i punti così posso
anche pensare di circondarli così
nessuno può raggiungerli dai sono
settimo
va avanti lungo questo no ma dove mi sta
un cinema mia quante lungo questo qua
madonna ma [ __ ] tua sorella
ma quanto era grosso ma mi chiaro un'ora
gamba avanti tutti i santi ecco così
almeno sembra ammazzate sapete che
scendono che ucciso tua madre io prendo
i punti degli altri poiché la gente si
mette in mezzo ma che cazzo vuoi pack è
frutto deficiente motoclub pur'io eccolo
lì bravo bravo gira gira gira tac
madonna sta gente contento questo è il
terzo ho beccato il terzo in classifica
che morisse cugino ai ho beccato il
terzo in classifica deficienti guardali
mi chiama beccato in dissi vabbeh ma
meno i back tra tutti quelli potrebbe
che a me no no rimango così a vita dopo
a vita finché non mi salvano qualcuno mi
salvi crepato perché le pa più
efficiente ed efficiente che aveva preso
ma lasciate grazie aveva magari è stato
magnanimo ma che magna ma si è
dimenticato ma [ __ ] dai è la lotta
contro il secondo in classifica ragazzi
vincerò io pezzo di merda o no quasi
maledizione dai amica incredibile non ce
la farai a fare quello che vuoi fare e
ce l'ha fatta
ti giuro che stavolta se mi lasci andare
di nuovo
faccio il bravo te lo giuro chi sei chi
è chi cosa
minchia vuoi dalla vita mia tu non
c'entrava in pene cosa vuoi ma ci son
ammazzando question madonna che
genocidio
oddio che cazzo succede ma per treni sia
ridotta la pagina
grande è bravissimo e morto madonna cosa
ho fatto non volevo farlo né tutti i
fratelli tutti fratelli tutti i fratelli
non ci facciamo la guerra tra di noi che
siamo belli non ci facciamo la guerra ba
morto che ne so io mi viene addosso e
dove è morto tutto libero a tutti i
fratelli morti tutti fratelli morti o
sono contento però che strana sta cosa
pam non è vero non è sono arrivato prima
io sono arrivato prima io perché sei
vivo madonna tutti quanti siamo
un gigante so che mi avesse la ucciso
era il secondo è secondo l'ho ucciso ha
ucciso su non ci posso credere come l'ho
ucciso non aveva senso già fottuti tutti
punti brutti stronzi
ma come ho fatto a ucciderlo mica
uccidere secondi classifica più
soddisfazioni che se prima un altro pò
di bella che l'ho ucciso e della tipo
aveva tipo qualcosa come 20 mila punti
ne ho presi neanche 2 milano preso
niente
[Musica]